[Music]
what happens when he gets out and
accuses me of things that are completely
untrue
is that all of a sudden that kindles the
crazies out there a person was arrested
who was on their way from sacramento and
he was going to washington d.c
to kill dr fauci go to
rand paul website and you see
fire dr fauci with a little box that
says contribute here so you are making a
catastrophic epidemic for your political
gain
that's dr fauci lashing out at senator
rand paul as tensions run high on
capital here at hill and here to react
to the fiery claims fox news contributor
tammy bruce they both went back and
forth we knew that was going to happen
tammy what did you think about yesterday
well it was an embarrassment for dr
fauci this is a man who
in all of his display all of his
responses
really confirmed the uh attitude that
we've all watched develop out of him
it is smug
at the an arrogance a disconnect uh it's
a rem it was a remarkable display and
you know rand paul what he did is he
looked at actual emails of dr fauci
conspiring with dr collins uh to take
down scientists uh from major
universities in this nation and in
england uh who disagree with the nature
of the approach with covet and it was a
discussion not about how to counter the
disagreements but about how to smear
them publicly i it's a remarkable
display but it really i have to tell you
ainsley reflects the rot that comes from
an entrenced bureaucracy these are
individuals who feel that they are
superior there is to be no contradiction
there's to be no criticism
they feel completely
unaccountable to anyone and they feel
that that's appropriate it is a mod it's
environment in in group think that and
this is why we have this debacle this is
the man who is leading uh this charge
against covid and it has been a disaster
he's been on every side of the every
major issue uh where the cove originated
from herd immunity masks the nature of
when this would end uh everything the
white house itself has said that they
were unprepared and
they just weren't ready for it for the
delta or the omicron variant fauci's in
charge of that so it's a it's an
embarrassment for fouchy it's an
embarrassment for this country and it's
dangerous for us as well yeah fauci said
you don't have to have masks well that
was false you're not going to get
coveted if you get vast and if you get
boosted well we know that's false he
didn't give money he says to for gain of
function research at wuhan according to
nih that's false and then when you heard
fauci blaming rand paul for the obscene
phone calls that his children and his
wife and he's getting at home and for
this guy who came from california across
and was pulled over by the cops and he
said he was going to kill fauci yeah
senator rand paul responded to that lara
listen to this
wife and i have been assaulted and
mobbed in the streets of d.c i had a
hater of president trump break six of my
ribs i've had part of my lung removed i
know what political violence is about i
don't wish any violence on on fouchy i
do wish you'd be fired though because i
think trusting the chinese is wrong i
think funding that lab in china is wrong
i think ignoring natural immunity is
wrong but i don't wish him any harm i
have been attacked and he's going to
come and blame his attacks on me it
wasn't fair it was a cheap shot but it
was a cheap shot by a politician not a
scientist
was it a cheap shot tammy
well it was and even there in that
response
rand paul responded with the details of
the issues of what his problems were
with what has unfolded fauci of course
did none of that he never answered any
of those questions and then at one point
in questioning with senator marshall who
was asking him about finances and his
own money and and with serious questions
who's also a doctor
in a hot mic fauci referred to him as a
[ __ ] now this tells you it reinforces
my point and what everyone is thinking
that this is a man who is obsessed only
with himself and not with solutions for
the country
yes steve was saying earlier that he did
release his financials but everything
that he gave over the course of the of
the year or the years of those
financials redacted so he's not being
transparent thank you so much tammy for
coming on with us
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now